okay so the topic of this video today is
going to be on one of the categories of
organic molecules called nucleic acids
now just to refresh our memory here are
the organic molecule categories all of
them carbohydrates lipids proteins and
nucleic acids I have a separate video
for each of these but this video
specifically looks at nucleic acids so
let's get started so you're often gonna
hear nucleic acids such as DNA being
compared to a blueprint well here's a
blueprint of a boat you know a blueprint
is a construction manual basically if
you have an engineering background you
could follow this blueprint and
construct the boat well nucleic acids
are instructions as well they are
instructions they're coded instructions
and they tell your cells and
particularly they tell your ribosomes
which are a part of your cell
they tell your ribosomes to build
proteins now how that process actually
works we'll discuss in a separate video
if you want you can search through my
library I have a video titled
translation and in that video I
discussed the process but for now we're
just going over some some some general
details so proteins are what DNA and RNA
the nucleic acids are blueprints to
build eventually they will tell your
cells how to build proteins so there's
two types of nucleic acids I just
mentioned these a moment ago DNA and RNA
we're gonna go into more details on each
of them in a few moments but you can see
from the picture that DNA is what we
call a double helix and RNA is simply a
single strand more on more in these
details in a few moments well as I've
said with all the other organic molecule
videos nucleic acids are an organic
molecule and they're made from smaller
organic molecules so a monomer is a
small part of an organic molecule and so
the monomer of a nucleic acid is what is
called a nucleotide but when one
nucleotide binds with another with
another with another it makes a larger
called a nucleic acid so monomers bond
to make polymers and in the world of
nucleic acids the monomer is called a
nucleotide and the polymer is a nucleic
so when we look at the monomer called a
nucleic acid in a little more detail you
know what's a nucleotide well it's a
monomer of a nucleic acid but let's look
at the molecular structure in a little
more detail if we kind of just isolate
one nucleic excuse me if we isolate one
nucleotide and then zoom on in we'll
often I see it in a very simplistic
diagram or drawing that kind of looks
like this so there are three parts to
the structure of a nucleotide you're
often going to see a Pentagon shaped
symbol and that represents the sugar
molecule now here in the bottom picture
this is the actual molecular formula of
the sugar that makes up DNA now I hope
you can see why it's often just kind of
shown as a Pentagon in various diagrams
that you might see another part labeled
P in the top picture is called the
phosphate group and in the bottom
picture you can see why it's called the
phosphate group first of all group
because there's a group of atoms and
phosphate because it's centered around
phosphorus and so it's very very often
in diagrams online in textbooks even in
this presentation you're gonna see
simply the phosphate group shown as just
a circle and in the top picture you can
see it's just a black circle with the
letter P in it and then we come to the
unique portion of a nucleotide the the
final part of a nucleotide is made up of
a nitrogen base now there are four
possible nitrogen bases and you can see
the letter abbreviations for each so
right now with the in the green box in
the top right hand corner there's a
letter a that stands for a molecule
called adenine there's three other
nitrogen bases there is a nitrogen base
labeled T which stands for thiamine
there is a nitrogen base labeled C which
stands for cytosine there's a nitrogen
base labeled G which stands for Guarani
in fact there's actually a fifth
nitrogen base called uracil with
standing with abbreviated with the
letter U
that's an RNA nucleotide we'll talk
about that later the four that you see
right here these are DNA nucleotide and
so what we're gonna show you a moment or
what I showed you earlier with the
simplistic orange circles connecting to
one another and here's a nucleotide
nucleotides combine to make larger
polymers remember the polymer is called
a nucleic acid so one nucleotide will
bond with a wide variety of others to
make a larger nucleic acid so if we were
in class I would give you a minute to
talk with your neighbor and try to work
out these five questions you know at
home right now pause the video and I'm
gonna go over these answers in three two
one okay so now that you've had time to
pause the video and try to answer these
on your own question number one how many
nucleotides are pictured well if you
just count the a's t's c's and g's i
hope you see there are six of them
number two all Toller what would this
long chain of nucleotides be called well
a whole collection of nucleotides is
called a nucleic acid number three name
the blue shaped Pentagon molecule that
typically the Pentagon shaped molecule
is gonna be the sugar there's three
parts to a nucleotide a sugar a
phosphate and a nitrogen base the
Pentagon shaped one that's gonna be the
sugar number four what are these
individual monomers called the
individual parts the six individual
parts that make up the overall nucleic
acid well there's a clue in number one
it says how many nucleotides are
pictured well those individual monomers
are called nucleotides and number five
what will these instructions be used to
create nucleic acids in general our
instructions to tell your cells how to
build a protein so let's move on so when
we look at specifically the nucleic acid
called DNA well talked about RNA in a
few moments but DNA in particular you're
gonna often hear the shape called a
double helix and in the animation a
helix simply means like a spiral
staircase a spiral
arrangement of a spiral ladder if you
imagine that in your mind and so double
because there's gonna be two strands of
nucleotides a strand on the left a
strand on the right you'll see what I
mean in just a moment so here is a
simplistic drawing of a strand of
nucleotides on the left and a strand of
nucleotides on the right this is what we
mean by the double in the word double
helix now I don't have in this in this
drawing here they're not twisted that
you know they'd be a little too tricky
to do with with you know PowerPoint but
you can see the double part of a double
helix and what holds those two strands
together what holds the left strand what
holds the right strand together are what
are called hydrogen bonds there's a
hydrogen bond in between the C and the G
on top there's a hydrogen bond in
between the a and the T on top and so on
as you go down and so one of the things
that was being uncovered in the early
part of the 1900s was the structure of
DNA and there was a scientist an
Austrian scientist by the name of Aaron
Schock F who discovered that the amount
of adenine was always equal to the
amount of thymine and for years we
didn't really know why but now we do the
reason the amount of adenine a is equal
to the amount of thymine T is because
they pair with one another and the
second observation the erwin chargaff
noticed was that the amount of G for
guanine was always equal to the amount
of C for cytosine and for years we
didn't really understand why and then it
was discovered that guanine and cytosine
G and C were bonded together so that's
why they were always appearing in equal
numbers so when we look at this picture
again we can see from top to bottom
anytime there's a C on the left there's
a G on the right anytime there's an A on
the Left there's a T on the right eight
pairs with T C pairs with G these are
called target chargaff's rule and so one
thing I also want to mention is that DNA
is made genes excuse me genes are made
of DNA I'm sure you've heard of genes
genetics you studied you know dominant
genes and recessive genes and autosomal
dominant autosomal recessive and well so
a gene is a portion it's a small chunk
of DNA that will eventually tell your
cell your ribosome in your cell how to
make a protein so for instance here's a
big chain of DNA in this picture for
instance let me just highlight that
small area right there pretend that's
gene a that combination of ATC's and G's
those come that combination of a STC's
and G's will ultimately tell your
ribosomes how to make a protein for
instance maybe that sequence right there
tells your ribosome how to make a
protein called hemoglobin you know
here's another gene that I just
highlighted gene B that little sequence
of a's t's c's and g's eventually holds
in the instructions to make a protein
called keratin and the ribosome will
receive these instructions then make a
and make the protein called keratin in
the last example let's highlight gene C
so that chunk of DNA right there pretend
is gene C C you can see that some genes
are bigger some genes are smaller and so
pretend that gene C is is the code the
set of instructions that eventually will
tell your ribosome to make a protein
called collagen so how the ribosome
makes a protein is not something we're
gonna discuss in this video but if you
want to look through my library of
videos it's a process called translation
I have a video on that you can check out
at your convenience so if we just kind
of take a stand back for a moment and
you know pause the video and try to
answer this question how many
nucleotides do you see in this picture
I'm gonna show the answer in three two
one
so a nucleotide remember is one
combination of a sugar phosphate in
nitrogen base and so I just highlighted
the answer there's twelve of them
there's six on the Left connected by
hydrogen bonds two six on the right so
what about the other kind of nucleic
acid ribonucleic acid well ribonucleic
acid from the picture you can see is a
bit different from DNA DNA if you recall
is the double helix the twists and
spiral-shaped staircase RNA is
it's a single chain of nuclei
nucleotides and so it's still a
combination of nucleotides so remember
nucleotide is a sugar a phosphate a
nitrogen base but notice how there is a
different nitrogen base there's still a
for adenine and C for cytosine and G for
guanine but in the world of RNA there is
no t4 thiamine you have a night a
different nitrogen base the letter U
stands for the nitrogen base by the name
of Europe and so in general this is very
in general here the the general purpose
of RNA is to deliver information from
from a DNA molecule to a ribosome on the
left is a DNA helix and remember we said
that DNA is the instructions to build a
protein well the problem is that the
ribosome is the actual physical builder
of the protein so that in the
instructions of DNA has to somehow get
to the ribosome the ribosome cannot
begin building a protein until it has
the instructions so the molecule that
goes in between the two is a type of RNA
by the name of messenger RNA so
messenger RNA will copy a piece of the
instructions of DNA take it over to the
ribosome and once the ribosome has the
instructions then the ribosome can live
up to its job the job of a ribosome is
to build proteins and then release the
proteins to wherever they are needed so
that's a very quick simplistic overview
of what of what RNA does again what
we'll go into more of this in detail
later on the school year in another
video so here we have kind of just a
summary table you know if we were in
class one minute discuss this with your
neighbor try to figure out what word
goes in box ABCD and E pause the video
think about it I'm going to go over the
answers in three two one so if you've
watched these videos in order nucleic
acids are the final organic molecule
that we're going to discuss so here's a
just a summary table the monomer of a
carbohydrates called mono
Sakurai the polymer of a carbohydrate
it's called a polysaccharide in proteins
the monomer of a protein is called an
amino acid in lipids the monomer of a
lipid it's actually two fatty acids are
one of the monomers as is the molecule
called glycerol a fatty acid and a
glycerol bond to make a lipid which is
the polymer and the last one which what
we discussed in this video today a
nucleotide is the monomer and a bunch of
nucleotides bond to make a polymer by
the name of a nucleic acid so there you
have it if you're one of my students you
know pause the video and try to answer
these on a separate sheet of paper I'd
be happy to check your answers before
school or after school good luck